now we're so excited about nightingale
because we got to see you when your
sister
is this the first time since I am Sam in
2009 it's I mean we still it's the first
time because I mean technically and I am
Sam I played her at a younger age so we
weren't really like acting together and
I were you know I was so young so yeah
this is the first why was this the right
project for you guys to finally do this
it was so exciting and special to to
finally find a script you know I think
we've been looking looking for something
for so long and this story is completely
it is a sister story that's the heart of
it and that's what what more could we
ask for you know I think we can you can
barely bring that sing that to it and
Melanie Melanie L'Orange is gonna direct
it and I've worked for before and she's
so incredible and she can really bring
something special she were excited so
you know saying we don't know what you
know what's gonna happen but we'll see
Elle Fanning dishing on finally working
with older sister Dakota on their
upcoming project the nightingale
if they're a chance it gets pushed back
to next year for a release date you
think I know you know I mean we haven't
shot it yet so that's the thing we
haven't shot we were about to go shoot
so and then you know everything happened
so it's kind of just put to a halt and I
know as much as much as you like yes
yeah what is it now
your real sisterhood that you're excited
to bring to the big screen as I mean I
don't know if you have a sister but you
do you okay yeah I mean there's just you
can explain that's just like your sister
knows you more than anyone I mean she
can sniff anything out of you she like
can push your buttons more than anybody
it's like that dynamic is so special and
unique they know your family more than
anybody you're like that's just the
clothes like she is my closest person
and the book really explores that
they're a bit miss more misunderstood I
would say in the in the book and in this
in this story but but still we have that
foundation and some that we won't
have to work hard for that'll be there
but first she stars in Hulu's new period
dramedy of the great alongside and
nicholas hoult how are you doing right
now I mean with everything going on are
you hanging in there what's what's life
like staying inside I'm in LA with my
family so that's nice just to have some
family time yes it's quite a nice way of
doing junket we have to talk about this
new show and I have to say huzzah yeah
you're the first person who said that
I'm surprised people haven't I know we
say so much I mean this show was such a
fun binge I watched all 10 episodes I
think over the the last three days so I
could so for you guys what was it about
this version of the story that really
kind of resonated with you I mean Tony
McNamara who is our showrunner creator
wrote the pilot and you know is the man
his tone and irreverence and just that
dark humor is completely up my alley and
I think telling this story which is you
know a piece of history and it's that
you know in a period world but turning
that on its head and dealing with themes
that are so modern and what they dealt
with back then it's just such a
fascinating way to tell that story full
of humor and really delicious language
and just Catherine as a character I
absolutely love playing her is just the
ultimate gift to be a part of the show
and and it to bring her to life and show
our version of Catherine you know of
course you know Catherine the Great is
truly this feminist icon of what she
brought to that brought to Russia and
her country and it's it's neat that we
get to show how she became that you know
cuz she doesn't start out knowing
everything so are this you know first
season really focuses on her journey
find
her power and herself but also just what
she believes in at the young woman
learning from others or sexuality like
it's all a part of it and that just
watching this young woman grow up so
that was it was cool to get to develop
that yeah I think you kind of summed it
up I loved playing Katherine he is a
really fun role to inhabit so on yeah
channeling Katherine's story and getting
to kind of delve into these characters
over 10 10 episodes and create this kind
of different take on it cuz I'm not a
fan of period dramas is such a finding a
little bit dry and no and this felt I
mean just completely different to those
um so it's yeah I just love the script
it made me chuckle I would like to be
useful to Russia to help it's great this
give em is there is no higher use this
did a little bit remind me of the
favorite and for obvious reasons I'm
sure you understand why people draw
those comparisons you were in the
favorite did you notice those
comparisons just in terms of like the
humor of it and the comedy of it all and
were some of the sets the thing we
didn't have a couple of similar
locations throughout the first episode
when we're shooting the pilot we shot
one of the same locations that we shot
some of the favorite at but yeah
obviously Tony's voice is that I know
say so
so idiosyncratic that having done the
favor I did recognize the kind of rhythm
and the pacing and that humor it's a
very different story that's told in a
similar tone we should find you or not
[Music]
mossis a lot of humor as we touched on
but also a lot of sex scenes in this
show how do you guys prepare for those I
don't think either of us really make a
big deal out of them I think I think the
thing with the sex scenes in this show
is there kind of their very perfunctory
in terms of what the characters are
aiming for or discussing during them
they're quite committed their very
comedic again for and there and it's
more about the story that that's that
physical beat is telling so kind of the
evolution for our two characters of
their physical interaction they were
very funny to film a lot of them I mean
Russia must be saved and I'm with it
like watched you grow up since here you
were like a tiny little thing you choose
he needs more mature roles that's
intentional I don't honestly know I
think that that is that the the answer
to it because I feel like as like roles
come to you you evolved because I'm
evolving
you know like I'm 22 I'm older than I
was when I when I started out so just by
nature of of that just the roles that
you get that are available you're older
and it opens up a whole new door to
different stories and different
characters I think that it's exciting to
to win that door you know has now opened
up and I get to see you like you know
other options whereas you know cuz when
you're a kid also you're auditioning and
you're you don't really have the choice
you know you're like you either that you
know the casting agent has the choice so
now it's nice that I feel like I get so
you know read scripts and kind of make
my own choices in that way but yeah I
think I'm just my characters are
evolving like like I am you know and
Katherine certainly does evolve in the
show you know she starts out very young
and it definitely grows up so yeah I
mean I don't want to give anything away
but I feel like even very much tells
like just one chapter of her stories is
there room for a season two is that the
talked about right now yeah I certainly
think there's a room for a season two
yeah and if they wanted to do it I would
do it right away but it'd be Catherine's
sort of beginning steps in power and
sort of the first things that she did
you know I wonder I was trying to like
I'm trying to pick my I'm trying to pick
Tony's brain about like what it is he's
definitely he's thinking about it he has
some idea but I would say to viewers
like this this season doesn't end the
way that you think it's going to end
[Music]